j'accueille jusqu'à minerai
[Applaudissements]
ghislaine villeray vous êtes la soeur de
jacques dit vrai et vous avez été choqué
par le livre de son ex-femme irina
villeray que nous avons reçu ici le 24
septembre dernier
magnéto serge fait connaissance ils vous
invitent heures son one man show et
après le spectacle qui vous invite à
dîner et ils vous révèlent sa blessure
en fait c'est à dire son père algérien
ce soir là au fil des eaux file des
verts le personnage s'assombrit il finit
par vous dire qu'il n'est pas programmé
pour vivre vous en déduisez quoi ça
m'émeut évidemment je rentre j'ai
entrepris immédiatement compassion quand
il a bu il vous fait peur car oui ça
fait peur parce que quelqu'un qui boit
quelqu'un qu'ils sont en prise d'une
drogue
il n'est plus tout à fait lui même et il
y avait ces espèces de crise qui pouvait
ressembler à des hommes très minces oui
où tout d'un coup oui il y avait des dd
il était il était violent mais c'est
vrai qu'ils cassaient tout ça fait peur
ça fait peur il avait une double
personnalité j'arrête et l'alcool y
aurait si c'est pas bien et ça le
faisait pas bien voyager voilà c'était
dans tout le monde en parle
ça vous a choqué se livrer cette
interview c'est tout à fait je dirais
même outré par ce que c'est présenté
jacques comme un monstre
ce qui l'était pas du tout vous saviez
que se livrent les sorties officielles
alors ce livre je savais qu'ils allaient
sortir mais je savais pas qu'ils
sortiraient sitôt puisque irina m'a
appelé après le décès de jacques donc
même après l'enterrement donc en février
pour me dire effectivement qu'elle
voulait écrire un livre en hommage à
jacques et sur leur grand amour sur leur
bonheur voilà et j'ai été stupéfaite
parce que j'ai vu le livre alors elle
vous a envoyé le livre avant qu'il sorte
moi elle me l'a pas envoyé mais elle
envoyait deux jours avant sa parution à
mes parents avec une dédicace avec toute
mon affection
[Musique]
bien sûr que mes parents ont été
effondré ce qui se comprend
elle a pris contact avec vous depuis la
sortie du livre ma vie
alors elle a pris contact avec moi allez
passer dans votre émission le samedi
elle m'appelait le lundi pour me
demander si monsieur ardisson m'avait
contacté ou si je l'avais contacté
rapport à ce que ce qui avait été dit
donc je lui ai raccroché ou quand elle
dit que votre frère n'était pas
programmé pour vivre c'est horrible
parce que jacques moi je l'avais
régulièrement au téléphone il était
heureux il avait plein de projets j'ai
passé noël avec lui mais par an il avait
beaucoup beaucoup de projets mais c'est
vrai qu'il a eu une enfance quand même
assez malheureuse assez difficile quand
même un nom il a pas eu une enfance
malheureuse il n'a pas été élevée par
son père géniteur il a pu le voir parce
qu'il voulait voir si lui ressembler
donc il était allé en algérie et il l'a
vu il m'a dit qu'il l'avait vu de loin
mais qui lui avait pas parlé et il l'a
vu une autre fois paris puisque son père
était venu au théâtre voir mais dans la
loge pas voir le spectacle
lorsqu'il avait besoin que jacques le
lay de niveau financier voilà par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils adorent et
ils adorent et mon père et quand elle
dit que jacques villeret appris que son
père enfin vraiment goût mais n'était
pas son vrai père elle dit qu'il l'a
appris à l'école
alors non ce sont mes parents qui lui
ont expliqué et il avait à peu près sept
ans donc c'est eux qui lui ont expliqué
tous les deux ravis que qu'il a appris à
l'école ça vous savez je peux pas vous
répondre parce qu'elle dit beaucoup de
choses qui sont pas dans lesquels
intérêt à dire ça c'est pas je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas en tout cas là il
vivre elle a écrit un livre un livre à
vendre donc il faut bien il faut bien le
remplir ce jeudi quand elle dit que
jacques a été enfoncée par son entourage
vous l'avez en france et vous votre
frère à nous jamais nous non non non le
seul la seule chose qu'il ya eu
effectivement jacky a été un moment
où on a été
un peu sans se voir parce qu'on l'avait
fait hospitaliser parce que sa santé se
dégrader
puisque effectivement c'est pas un scoop
avec elle révèle jacques a beaucoup bu
mais surtout au moment du divorce parce
que ça a été vraiment une épreuve atroce
pour lui vraiment et moi je sais que je
l'avais des nuits entières au téléphone
il comprenait pas puisqu'il me disais
c'est comment j'ai pu vivre 20 ans à
côté d'une femme qui qui m'a tout pris
kim à tous et ce sont ces termes je le
nom elle dit que j'ai acquis a été en
français par son entourage parce que par
exemple quand il venait chez vous il
paraît que c'est vous qui lui proposait
de boire des apéritifs de boire de
l'alcool
c'est ce qu'elle dit alors qu elle au
contraire essayé de le retenir
non mais pas du tout moi vous savez j'ai
vécu des temps chez eux puisque j'ai
vécu un moment à paris je l' ai vu des
fois où
elle cherchait à énerver jacquot et lui
disait les bois et nerveux toi moi je
les ai vus donc ouais c'est vrai qu'il
la battait non alors ça je peux dire que
c'est complètement faux nom jacques
comme beaucoup de gens quand il avait bu
pouvait être agressif verbalement mais
comme il avait pu le faire certains
moments quand moi je l'avais au
téléphone
à côté de ça ça devenait si on rentrait
pas dans son énervement
ça devrait être ça devenait très
théâtral jusqu'à la limite moi j'ai fini
c'est même pas en sourire en me disant
bon demain ça ira mieux et est bon c'est
le moment
quand elle dit que jacques villeret lui
devait sans succès je pense que jacques
avait suffisamment de talent pour
arriver au succès qu'il a connu tout
seul parce qu'il sera arrivé avec
n'importe quelle autre femme
donc bien sûr bien sûr dès l'âge de 8
ans il voulait tracteur donc il vivait
que pour ça je vais parce qu'il l'aimait
vraiment lui oui oui bien sûr c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'il a été si effondré au
moment du divorce
ils ont divorcé pourquoi mais parce que
un jour jacques est sorti de chez lui il
s'est trouvé nez à nez 8 s'occupait pas
des papiers
et il s'est trouvé nez à nez avec un
huissier qui a bien recommandé avec une
tête d'impôts importantes
donc il a demandé il a dit à irin à je
comprends pas qu'est ce que c'est que ça
aille à lui a dit t'inquiète pas les
impôts ils font des erreurs au niveau de
l'informatique
et puis forcément lui il a été se
renseigner et là il a compris que non
seulement les impôts étaient pas payer
mais l'argent n'était plus là non plus
l'argent n'était plus là pour payer les
impôts et lui ce jour là il a décidé de
divorcer
c'est à dire qu'il a été un petit moment
où il y croyait pas il nous appelait en
disant mais j'y crois pas c'est pas
possible il ya il ya autre chose je
crois pas et puis il s'est rendu compte
qu effectivement après toutes les
démarches que c'était bien la réalité
est là il s'est effectivement il fondera
qui a ruiné l'autre parce qu'elle elle
dit que jacques villeret la ruine est ce
que vous vous entendez celle inverse
oui c'est à dire que je crois qu'elle
l'a ruiné effectivement parce que
jacques a quand même toujours travaillé
donc je pense qu'on sait que un acteur
comme lui qui travaille 30 ans de sa vie
se retrouver sans rien si un peu
surprenant alors que jacques et dépenser
de l'argent c'est bien normal ils ont
gagné parce que c'est aussi dire ça mais
à côté de ça il aurait dû en rester
beaucoup et ça il a recherché ne
comprenais pas elle perçoit de l'argent
quand il ya des films de jacques
villeret qui passe la télévision alors
moi je suis pas trop trop courant mais
je crois qu'elle perçoit toujours je
crois pourquoi l'atelier d'après-vous
ghislaine je comprends pas bien je
comprends pas bien parce que moi même
j'étais surprise mais non c'est je
trouve que c'est le salir et bien sûr il
est plus là pour répondre
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile c'est
pour ça qu'on est à la télévision je
fais tout à fait pour défendre la
mémoire de votre frère tout à fait parce
que nous on est des gens très discrets
autrement je veux réparer
oui là je trouve que ça va un peu trop
loin
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire irina villeray ce soir j'espère
simplement qu'elle sait ce qu'elle cesse
parce que sinon effectivement peut-être
qu'on se contentera pas des médias
voulaient attaquer au tribunal pourquoi
pas je sais pas si elle veut aller
beaucoup plus loin oui
mais à ses yeux le témoignage islam
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu